(swishing)
(swinging)
- I'm a little bit
nervous to see what you're
going to choose 'cus it's
gonna be on my body forever
but I'm also excited.
(mellow music)
I have 17 tattoos now.
I have a Gandhi quote that says,
"Live like you will die tomorrow.
Learn like you will live forever."
My dad is a veteran so
I wanted to do something
that made me think of him.
I was thinking for my
next tattoo, I want to get
something on my lower back.
I've battled a lot with
eating disorders and crippling
anxiety and depression
and chronic illness.
My life isn't perfect but
it's definitely gotten
to a really good place.
And I also, sort of wanna combine
that to commemorate my mom
why, because she's a huge
part of who I am and who I'm
becoming and when she passed it was
a really huge turning point in my life.
She was able to exhibit such grace
and even in the most horrific situations.
She was calm and loving and patient and
she saw people not
for just who they were
but for who they could be.
She saw the good in everyone
and tried to push them
to become better.
Now it's up to you to pick my tattoo
and a tattoo artist here at Body Electric
is going to design something
and I'm not going to see it
until it's on my body, so
be nice to me. (laughs)
(upbeat electronic music)
(swishing)
- Today I'm tattooing Heather.
These people from internet
gave me the idea to do it.
So this idea is basically, it's a big wave
made it with small waves.
In life you can break big
problems with small problems
and then you make everything more easy.
(swishing)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I feel pretty anxious,
and a little bit on edge,
but I'm also really excited.
The best case scenario
is that I will love it
and it will be beautiful.
The worst case scenario is
that it will be something
that I don't like and I
might have to invest in some
laser removal down the road.
I'm ready to be surprised!
(upbeat electronic music)
(drilling)
- All right, Heather.
(buzzing)
It's pretty much done.
- Yay!
- Are you ready to see it?
- I'm ready.
(booming)
I feel like I'm gonna be
relieved when I see it.
- One, two, three.
(gasps)
- Oh wow! It's beautiful!
I love it! I'm really relieved.
I'm super happy.
I love what it represents
and I really like that
that's the conclusion
that the internet came to
given the stories that I told.
Even though your problems
can seem really huge
in comparison with the big
picture. They're really not.
I feel like it really represents
where I've been in my life
and where I am.
Thank you internet!
Thank you Jacob!
- Thank you!
- So much!
- Good job!
- Yay!
(upbeat electronic music)
(swishing)